wie schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute mit diesem thema keine
lohnfortzahlung für ungeimpfte in
quarantäne
ungeimpfte arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer sollen ab dem ersten
november keine lohnfortzahlung bekommen
wenn sie in corona quarantäne sind das
haben die gesundheitsminister der länder
heute beschlossen und das gilt dann für
alle ungeimpften menschen die sich
eigentlich impfen lassen können
bundesweit ist das gerecht oder
ungerecht was meint ihr schreibt uns
gerne direkt im stream in die kommentare
oder stellt eure fragen oder schreibt
die kommentare an die jetzt gerade
eingeblendete mail adresse wir wollen
heute darüber sprechen zum einen mit
unserem rechtsexperten felix zimmermann
hallo felix ein bisschen später in der
sendung allerdings erst denn zunächst
werden wir sprechen mit karl lauterbach
spd gesundheitsexperte und mit erwin
rüddel von der cdu vorsitzender des
gesundheitsausschusses im deutschen
bundestag aber erst noch mal zu den
fakten also bislang war es so dass
beschäftigte in corona quarantäne
entweder weil sie gereist sind oder aber
weil sie als kontaktperson galten
anspruch hatten auf den vollen lohn
sechs wochen lang bezahlt vom staat das
hat das infektionsschutzgesetz geregelt
und das soll sich jetzt eben nun ändern
ab erster november bundesweit für alle
nicht geimpften menschen denn inzwischen
so lautet ein argument könne jeder der
sich impfen lassen möchte auch geimpft
werden der bundesgesundheitsminister
spahn sprach hier im zdf bei uns von
fairness gegenüber den geimpften und da
wollen wir jetzt kurz noch mal in eine
zusammenfassung reinschauen von britta
spiekermann und claudia formann
ein maschinenbauunternehmen in
baden-württemberg 2000 beschäftigte in
diesem bundesland gilt bereits wer
ungeimpft wegen co mit 19 in quarantäne
muss der bekommt keine lohnfortzahlung
mehr das geht nicht bei erkrankung aber
wenn die quarantäne aus
sicherheitsgründen erfolgt der chef hält
das für einen problematischen eingriff
also wir als unternehmen glauben daran
dass es ihnen hilft die pandemie zu
bekämpfen aber dass die politik jetzt
versucht durch die hintertür unternehmen
die menschen zu zwingen sich impfen zu
lassen halten wir nicht für den
richtigen weg was in baden württemberg
gilt auch andere länder sind schon
vorgeprescht soll bis spätestens erster
november bundesweit umgesetzt werden
heute einigten sich gesundheitsminister
von bund und ländern es geht um die
umsetzung nicht kann es nur noch mal
sagen eines bestehenden gesetzes und wir
glauben auch dass wir da konsequent
bleiben müssen es werden ja auch ab dem
11 10 die kostenlosen tests in manchen
bereichen wegfallen auch das ist eine
konsequenz und ich kann nur jetzt noch
mal alle auffordern sich wirklich impfen
zu lassen für
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen ist
impfen ein gebot der fairness und
solidarität
diejenigen die sich und andere durch
eine impfung schützen
haben ja dann auch die berechtigte frage
warum eigentlich für jemanden der im
urlaub war ein risikogebiet und weil er
nicht geimpft ist der dann in quarantäne
muss warum sie dann für so jemand mit
zahlen gewerkschaften kritisieren es
bestehe schließlich keine impfpflicht
zudem gebe es erhebliche
datenschutzprobleme hier entstehen neue
konflikte in quarantäne fall muss dann
der arbeitgeber die den nachweis
erhalten warum eine kern zähne
angeordnet wurde und das gibt dann
rückschlüsse auf die gesundheitliche
verfassung der beschäftigten und das ist
genau das was wir nicht wollen wer sich
nicht impfen lassen kann der muss dies
im quarantäne fall mit einem attest
nachweisen die kanzler kandidaten und
die kandidatin heute auf
wahlkampfveranstaltungen
seltene einigkeit bei der bundesweit
gestrichenen lohnfortzahlung für
ungeübte kurzum der druck soll erhöht
werden sich impfen zu lassen der hebel
finanzielle nachteile
wir sprechen nun mit rwe erwin redl von
der cdu mit karl lauterbach von der spd
schon guten abend herr
rolle wie auch der und hanno wie auf den
gesundheitsminister sparen rödl stehen
sie hinter diesen beschluss warum
ja ich denke alle haben mittlerweile die
möglichkeit sich impfen zu lassen im 5
hilft uns die pandemie zu überwinden und
deshalb denke ich ist es ein gebot der
fairness und der solidarität gegenüber
den geimpften das also für die
ungeimpften nicht noch mehr kosten durch
die gesellschaft entstehen dürfen
herr lauterbach sie hatten kritik
geäußert an diesem beschluss und
erzählen sie mal worum ging es ihnen da
genau sie haben sich also da kritisch
dazu geäußert
ja ich habe die sorge dass der schuss
nach hinten losgeht dass diejenigen die
kontaktpersonen waren und somit dem
quarantäne fall kasey kahne lohn bekämen
das sie sich gar nicht mehr als
kontaktpersonen melden denn wir können
sie ja nicht zwingen also wenn jetzt zum
beispiel fünf personen in einem fahrzeug
unterwegs gewesen sind und andere war
infiziert
dann können die vier anderen also dieser
regel leicht also entkommen indem sie
anfangs kontaktpersonen nie genannt
werden und vielleicht ist einer oder
zwei von ihnen also infiziert dann wird
sich die pandemie sogar weiter
verbreiten dann hätten wir zum schluss
auch kein geld gespart sondern einfach
mehr kranke also ich habe einfach die
sorge dass das einfach viel zu leicht
auszuhebeln ist wir werden
wahrscheinlich kaum mehr kontaktpersonen
genannt bekommen wenn klar ist dass man
für den quarantäne fall keine
lohnfortzahlung er bekommt
teilen sie diese bedenken an so könnten
sie sich auch vorstellen dass das dazu
führt dass also einige menschen sich
dann vielleicht nicht mehr in quarantäne
begeben oder dass vielleicht
verschweigen dass sie dann kontaktperson
bahn teilen sie das
also ich habe diese sorge nicht außerdem
haben wir auch die pflicht
diese solidarität die die geimpften für
die ungeimpften ausüben nicht nicht zu
überspannen es ist ich glaube dass wir
ein gutes system haben die
gesundheitsämter
ermitteln die infizierten schicken diese
menschen in quarantäne und müssen das
natürlich auch entsprechend
kontrollieren also ich glaube dass es
also ein gebot der gerechtigkeit ist
wenn
wir hier konsequenz sind weil wenn wir
nicht konsequent sind dann über fordern
wir die gesellschaft und gerade auch die
mehrheit in der gesellschaft die ja
nicht nur dann für die gesundheitskosten
der ungeimpften aufkommen sondern
natürlich auch dann für die
lohnfortzahlung aufkommen müssen obwohl
die sich schützen könnten und es bewusst
nicht tun weil jeder die chance hat sich
impfen zu lassen
und wir setzen dieses gesetz oder diese
vereinbarung ja ist um zum ersten elf
und bis zum 11 11 könnte jeder noch von
heute an gerechnet sich die erste und
die zweite impfung abholen so dass man
also gar nicht erst in die verlegenheit
kommt wenn das wenn die vereinbarung in
kraft tritt ist auch eine eine debatte
über fairness und gerechtigkeit die
damit angestoßen wurde viele appellieren
jetzt auch noch mal an die
impfbereitschaft der menschen auch wenn
es eben am ende natürlich eine freie
entscheidung bleibt und wir hören da mal
rein was der bayerische
gesundheitsminister und auch noch mal
gesundheitsminister sparen dazu heute
gesagt hat
wer heute auf die intensivstation im
blick der sieht dass dort eigentlich
fast ausschließlich menschen sind die
nicht geimpft sind und wer den an eine
hilfestellung geben will die dort um
diese menschen leben kämpfen den
pflegerinnen und pflegern und den ärzten
der sollte sich impfen lassen weil er
schwere krankheitsverläufe vermeiden
kann und weil er damit am meisten auch
die unterstützt die dort jeden tag
wirklich ein herz aussagen dienst
leisten und dann ist es eben auch
wichtig wenn menschen sagen es ist ihre
freie persönliche entscheidung das
bleibt es auch ob sie sich impfen lassen
oder nicht dass mit dieser entscheidung
dann eben auch die verantwortung kommt
finanzielle folgen zu tragen das gilt
bei den tests die ab dem 11 oktober
nicht mehr kostenlos sind für den
restaurantbesuch für die veranstaltung
und das gilt eben ab dem ersten november
spätestens in allen ländern dann auch
für die quarantäne zahlung
eine frage an sie beide glauben sie denn
jetzt dass mit diesem beschluss die
impfbereitschaft dann vielleicht
tatsächlich tatsächlich gesteigert
werden werden kann herr lauterbach was
das sagen sie dazu
ich glaube das nicht also wer geht denn
hin und überlegt also ich lasse mich
jetzt eben weil sonst die
lohnfortzahlungen wegfällt wenn ich eine
kontaktperson bin es kann doch jeder
schlicht und ergreifend das leicht
umgehen und meldet sich nicht als
kontaktpersonen oder bestreitet
kontaktpersonen gewesen zu sagen gibt im
restaurants ab beispielsweise einen
falschen namen an oder registriert sich
gar nicht also ich glaube dass also
ehrlich gesagt an viel wahrscheinlicher
das ergebnis dass sein wird dass wir von
den ohnedies zu wenigen kontaktpersonen
die wir jetzt noch erfassen wir erfassen
ja nur noch einen sehr kleinen teil der
kontaktpersonen die also
gesundheitsämter verfassen höchstens
noch die hälfte der kontaktpersonen
wahrscheinlich weniger dass dieser
anteil noch weiter sinken wird und wir
möglicherweise nachher nur noch einen
bruchteil der kontaktpersonen in
quarantäne schicken können
harel warum ist ihre hoffnung da größer
dass es vielleicht doch eben auch ein
impf anreiz vielleicht sein könnte
also ich denke es ist auf jeden fall
eine anregung darüber nachzudenken es
gibt menschen in der gesellschaft die
wollen sich bewusst mutwillig nicht
impfen lassen und es gibt sicherlich
auch menschen die etwas nachlässig sind
und deshalb glaube ich dass die oder der
ein oder andere hier neue nachdenkt und
vielleicht doch die entscheidung trifft
sich impfen zu lassen
wir werden ja parallel jetzt in den
nächsten wochen auch die chance geben
dass also kinder ab fünf geimpft werden
können und ich glaube mit all diesen
maßnahmen
sensibilisierung
zugehende im für angebote im chancen
auch für kinder werden wir gut über den
winter kommen
zusätzlich mit den zweig oder zweig plus
regeln oder wenn es um öffentliche
staatliche angebote sich handelt 3g
regelungen also ich bin zuversichtlich
dass wir hier ohne dass es einen
erneuten lockdown geben muss auch nicht
für die
ungeimpften
dass wir hier chancen eröffnen
sensibilisieren darauf hinweisen dass
man diese chance nutzen soll auch aus
solidarität der gesellschaft gegenüber
und wenn das auch keine massenbewegung
sein wird ich denke wir sollten über
jeden kleinen schritt froh sagen dass
menschen sich impfen lassen
wir haben dazu auch einige kommentare
bei uns im stream bei youtube da wollen
wir vielleicht mal kurz zusammen
reinschauen und auch nochmal der aufruf
an euch dass ihr aber natürlich auch
jederzeit gerne fragen stellen könnt
aber zunächst mal zu ein paar kommentare
und meinungen dazu melanie schreibt bei
youtube ich finde das fair dass die
keinen lohn kriegen sie belasten das
system yvonne schreibt meine beste
freundin ist ungeimpft und sagt auch
immer jetzt erst recht nicht je mehr
druck desto mehr gegenwehr also dann
gibt es hier tatsächlich sehr
unterschiedliche meinungen luckow
schreibt bei youtube ich denke dass
diesem winter die tests noch bezahlt
werden sollten wenn doch auch früher
herdenimmunität
bestehen soll und so gibt es da sehr
viele unterschiedliche kommentare und
meinungen und wie gesagt noch mal der
aufruf gerne an euch auch fragen zu
stellen an herrn lauterbach und herrn
rodeln
wir wollen jetzt noch einmal reinhören
auch in ein weiteres statement von
gesundheitsminister sparen der sich
heute noch mit folgender kritik auch
geäußert hat
wer sich die gesetzliche regelung im
infektionsschutzgesetz anschaut da stets
sehr klar der anspruch auf diese
erstattung auf diese lohnersatzleistung
entfällt wenn eine entsprechende
schutzimpfung empfohlen ist und im
mittlerweile auch ausreichend verfügbar
ist insofern gilt das gesetz das unter
anderem auch der abgeordnete lauterbach
mit entschieden hat hier dann eben für
alle bürgerinnen und bürger da ist
geltendes recht anzuwenden
herr lauterbach der gesundheitsminister
hat sie da hier auch ein wenig
kritisiert beziehungsweise er hat gesagt
sie hätten das gesetz damals eben auch
mit unterzeichnet hat sich denn
irgendetwas an ihrer meinung von damals
geändert
naja es war ein gesetz welches viele
teile gehabt hat und das war ein aspekt
und diesen aspekt habe ich damals schon
kritisch gesehen somit also muss man
dafür seien also natürlich war das teil
eines gesamtpaketes und das gesamtpaket
war es wert zuzustimmen aber den einen
aspekt den habe ich damals schon fast
von finden weiterhin weil die frage ist
unbeantwortet wie wir verhindern dass
wir schlicht die kontaktpersonen ganz
aus dem auge verlieren ich war doch noch
einen satz zu diesem fairness argument
sagen also das kann aus der perspektive
der ungeimpften die den lohn dann nicht
bekommen auch anders gesehen werden also
ich bin dafür dass wir viel machen um
die ungeimpften zur impfung zu bringen
und bin zum beispiel auch für relativ
strenge zweig regeln aber wenn der
ungeimpfte jetzt beispielsweise in
kontakt gewesen ist mit einem
infizierten geimpften diese leute gibt
es ja auch wir wissen ja dass also
infizierte geimpfte ebenfalls also zu
nehmen war die impfung an also schutz
verliert dann würde quasi der ungeimpfte
keine lohnfortzahlung bekommen weil er
in kontakt gewesen ist mit einem
infizierten geimpften das würde der
ungeimpfte als ungerecht empfinden
findet daher diesen schritt dass man
hingeht und sagt okay wir machen jetzt
druck wir nehmen ist also am
portemonnaie also ihr bekommt keine
lohnfortzahlung es sei denn ihr in
österreich das ist möglicherweise der
punkt wo wir die schraube etwas über
drehen und die haben dann auch noch die
gefahr wie gesagt dass du die kontrolle
der pandemie ein stück rat verlieren
natürlich ist es schön dass wir
demnächst impfstoffe für die kinder
haben das ist richtig aber wir müssen
tatsächlich die ungeimpften erreichen
und also mein eindruck ist der dass
diese regelung von vielen als ungerecht
empfunden werden könnte herr lauterbach
sie haben die fairness angesprochen und
sie stehen damit ihrer kritik auch nicht
alleine also gewerkschaften und
sozialverbände schließen sich da an auch
verena bentele präsidentin des
sozialverbandes vdk und auch hier haben
wir einen o ton von ihr indem ihr gerne
mal reinhören möchte im
gesundheitssystem ist dafür da dass eben
gerade und insbesondere menschen die ihm
dringend auch natürlich ihr einkommen
zur existenzsicherung brauchen daneben
auch geld haben und zwei wochen kein
geld haben das bedroht die existenz
gerade und insbesondere von ärmeren
menschen ganz klar muss die regelung
jetzt seien im land ohne impfpflicht das
eben auch alle lohnfortzahlung kriegen
auch die nicht kämpfen
herr rödl sie stehen ja klar hinter
diesen beschluss teilen sie diese kritik
marken
mein freiheits rahmen endet da wo ich
also den freiheits rahmen eines anderen
berühre und deshalb halte ich es also
für nicht sozial nur an mich zu denken
der in dieser frage als ungeimpfte
sondern ich muss auch daran denken dass
die die sich haben impfen lassen dazu
beigetragen haben dass wir diese
pandemie bisher so gut überstanden haben
und die geimpften sind bereit die
erkrankung der ungeimpften zu
finanzieren und ich denke irgendwo sind
dann auch grenzen gesetzt wo diese
solidarität überfordert wird und deshalb
denke ich hat jeder die chance sich
impfen zu lassen und muss abwägen welche
konsequenzen für ihn wichtiger sind sich
nicht impfen zu lassen das risiko
einzugehen oder auf lohnfortzahlungen zu
verzichten also diese und wie gesagt wir
haben ja extra auch einen gewissen
zeitrahmen gewählt erst der elfte damit
man die chance hat sich noch impfen zu
lassen und wir brauchen um also die
herdenimmunität zu erreichen viele
geimpfte wir werden genesene haben und
von denen die heute noch nicht geimpft
sind die werden an corona erkranken in
den nächsten wochen monaten fleisch in
den nächsten zwei drei jahren
und die solidarität in der gesellschaft
ist so groß dass also die geimpften
deren genesung finanzieren obwohl sie
sich hätten schützen können also ich
denke es ist der bogen eventuell etwas
überspannt wer neben den krankheits und
genesungsverlauf
die gesellschaft noch die
lohnfortzahlung zahlen sollen
sie sprechen die kosten
bitte sie können gerne direkt darauf
reagieren
also gern noch etwas erwidern und also
darauf hinweisen wie gefährlich diese
argumentation ist also
selbstverständlich ist das also ein
argument was man machen kann aber wenn
man so argumentiert dann ist ein schritt
weiter der schritt wo man sagt naja wenn
die ungeimpften erkranken dann müssen
sie auch die eigene behandlung bezahlen
also wenn ich schon sagen dass der
ungeimpften dass herr professor
lauterbach ich wüsste niemanden der
diese äußerungen so getan hätte die die
gesellschaft bezahlt
da kann ich die ware nicht mehr
verstehen wir müssen uns zumindest uns
ausleben
erst der kurze ausspricht und dann herr
übel können sie direkt darauf reagieren
erst mal
natürlich hat bisher noch niemand
vorgeschlagen dass die ungeimpften im
krankheitsfall zur strafe das eben nicht
die impfung genommen haben ihre
behandlung selber bezahlen das hat noch
niemand vorgeschlagen aber es liegt in
der gleichen denkt local wenn ich sage
dass die ungeimpften in quarantäne fall
keinen lohn bekommen dann ist es nur
noch ein kleiner schritt bis sorge
mentha zion wird der ungeimpfte kann das
hat noch niemand vorgeschlagen dass sie
auch nicht aber wird der ungeimpfte
krank dann muss er auch die behandlung
bezahlen
wäre gerne direkt jetzt nach übrigen
herr professor lauterbach die diese
diese gedanken halte ich für sehr
gefährlich die sie jetzt hier äußern und
sie haben ja ausdrücklich gesagt dass
diese erklärungen auch noch niemand
gebracht hat und ich halte das auch für
für
wichtig dass es also diese entwicklungen
nicht geben darf und auch jetzt bei der
lohnfortzahlung also wenn wenn jemand an
corona erkrankt ob geimpft oder nicht
geimpft dann wird er die gleiche
behandlung bekommen und die kosten
werden von unserem gesundheitssystem
übernommen ob geimpft oder nicht geimpft
und wenn jemand an corona erkrankt dann
hat auch wenn er nicht geimpft ist dann
hat er auch einen anspruch auf
lohnfortzahlung es geht hier um die die
sich hätten schützen können gesund sind
und in quarantäne geschickt werden wie
also man muss ja ganz man muss hier ganz
die verbot differenzieren wir sehen hier
gibt es zwei unterschiedliche meinungen
und das kann ich auch im chat lesen wir
haben ja auch eine zeitverzögerung also
wir sehen hier es gibt es wirklich viele
unterschiedliche meinungen auch in euren
kommentaren kann ich das lesen wir
wollen einige von diesen fragen jetzt
auch gleich hier im studium mit unserem
rechtsexperten felix zimmermann
besprechen deswegen bedanke ich mich
jetzt an dieser stelle bei ihnen beiden
bei karl lauterbach und erwin rüddel
vielen dem dank dass sie sich heute
amtszeit für diese diskussion genommen
haben danke
schön amt
und nun wollen wir ein paar genau von
diesen schwierigen fragen bei diesem
thema besprechen mit felix zimmermann
unserem rechtsexperten hin im studio
felix wir haben eben gerade gehört es
gibt da wirklich also zwei
argumentationslinien jetzt mal ganz
faktisch rechtlich nüchtern darauf
geguckt was spricht für die neue für den
neuen beschluss und was spricht dagegen
also ganz nüchtern dafür spielt erstmal
das gesetz ja weil da steht es wie
ersparen zutreffend sagt wirklich ganz
klar drin es gibt diesen § 56 mhz
infektionsschutzgesetz und da steht eben
eine entschädigung erhält nicht wer
durch inanspruchnahme einer
schutzimpfung die gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben ist ist sie nicht oder
empfohlen ist dass sie
quasi selbst verschuldet dass er in
quarantäne muss die haben eine ganz
klare gesetzliche regelung die
eigentlich von schon die ganze zeit gilt
insofern ist dieser beschluss eigentlich
nun agreement unter den ländern dass sie
das jetzt auch so umsetzen wollen und
auch angehen wollen was ja auch einige
schon getan haben in den letzten wochen
wenn ihr fragen habt an unseren
rechtsexperten felix zimmermann gerne
die herzliche einladung die jetzt noch
zu stellen im stream oder per mail und
wir sprechen hier im studio weiter denn
ich glaube es gibt da viele offene
punkte auch noch die es zu klären gilt
zb auch woher weiß denn der arbeitgeber
oder kann er überhaupt wissen ob jemand
geimpftes oder ob er nicht geimpft das
darüber wurde ja in der vergangenheit
auch schon oft diskutiert
genau gewusst jetzt erst mal das
produziert aber nochmal klären wie läuft
das läuft so dass der arbeitnehmer
eigentlich erstmal weiter bezahlt werden
muss vom arbeitgeber und der arbeitgeber
der kein lohn mehr hat also eine schöne
und da keine arbeitskraft mehr hat der
kann dann einen antrag stellen diese
summe vom staat erstattet zu bekommen so
wenn er jetzt diesen antrag stellt oder
ob das in bayern zb so dass dann
angekreuzt werden muss gegenüber der
behörde war denn ihr arbeitnehmer
geimpft oder nicht und spätestens dann
was natürlich der arbeitnehmer gefragt
werden und da streiten jetzt die
gewerkschaften auf der einen seite und
so ein bisschen die arbeitgeberverbände
auf der anderen seite ob das überhaupt
zulässig ist aus datenschutzrechtlichen
gründen weil eigentlich muss der
arbeitnehmer ja nur in ganz bestimmten
fällen der gesundheitsbranche gegenüber
dem arbeitgeber sagen aber geimpft ist
oder nicht es geht ihr nicht überall
diese auskunftspflicht des arbeitnehmers
hier kann man auch sagen es ist
vielleicht eine spezielle regelung wo
dann der arbeitnehmer in das kreuzchen
machen muss bei dem antrag ja und dann
weiß der arbeitgeber eben bescheid das
ist sozusagen ein punkt aber auf der
anderen seite überprüft denn ob diese
angabe überhaupt richtig ist dass eines
der probleme was die durchsetzung hier
angeht und wie sieht es zum beispiel aus
jetzt für den fall dass jemand der nicht
geimpft ist corona bekommt das könnte ja
auch passieren dass es dann los genau
das muss man also ganz stark
unterscheiden weil das geht hier nicht
um die lohnfortzahlung die
arbeitsrechtlich besteht sonst geht
wirklich nur um die frage wenn man in
quarantäne muss weil man mit jemandem
zusammen war der korona cupid 19
bekommen hat oder eben aus einem
hochrisiko beat zurück kommt und
deswegen krone muss also im
krankheitsfall geht weiter die normale
lohnt vor zahlung im krankheitsfall es
betrifft nur diese absonderung aus
sicherheitsgründen das ist der sinn und
zweck dahinter wir haben hier eine frage
von fleishman zu youtube und zwar hallo
zimmermann mein bruder wie können wir
und
wie können wir ungeimpfte verklagen dass
sie hohe geldstrafen zahlen können also
können ich glaube die frage bedeutet
können nicht geimpfte menschen denn
verklagt werden ja also hier geht es
erstmal darum dass sie etwas weiter
haben wollen nämlich ihren lohn ja aber
dahinter steckt ist ein bisschen die
frage die jetzt auch in der diskussion
angeklungen ist nach dieser
verantwortung und da muss man natürlich
sagen insgesamt in unserem rechtssystem
oder auch gesundheitssystem gilt jetzt
nicht dass nur wenige staatliche
leistung bekommt er sich besonders
sauber ordentlich und gesundheitsbewusst
verhält also jemand der raucht wird ja
auch im krankenhaus zb behandelt wenn er
krank ist jemand der zu schnell fährt
und so weiter und so fort also
eigentlich ist der soldat gemeinschaft
als gedanke durchaus immanent dass man
auch leute leuten mit unterstützt die
sich vielleicht nicht ganz so verhalten
wie das öffentlich gewünscht ist ja und
um die frage von krebs beantworten
verklagen kann man die jetzt nicht auf
was auch und wir haben uns auch immer
wieder über fairness gesprochen und über
gerechtigkeit aber wenn man jetzt eben
nüchtern und rein rechtlich da drauf
guckt also spielt so was wie da könnte
jemand benachteiligt werden später das
am ende dann überhaupt eine rolle das
spielt natürlich eine rolle denn dass
ungeimpfte
schlechter behandelt werden in der
gesellschaft das muss immer sehr gut
begründet werden es geht ja in anderen
bereichen auch nicht und da gibt es eben
an vielen stellen zweifel insbesondere
dann wenn die krone lage entspannt wir
stellen uns mal vor die inzidenz werni
trägt die krankenhäuser werden allesamt
leer dann wird es irgendwann nicht mehr
gerechtfertigt zum beispiel einem zweig
regelungen zu machen und natürlich muss
die regel dann auch immer sinnvoll so
ein geeignet erforderlich und
verhältnismäßig weil sie ihm in
grundrechte eingreift bzw den
gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz der auch im
grundgesetz steht widersprechen kann
muss immer einen guten grund zur
differenzierung geben und die haben wir
jetzt die argumente gehört ob das hier
der fall ist ist zweifelhaft denn die
frage ist ja wirklich hilft es oder wie
herr lauterbach warf man befürchtet
verschlimmert ist sogar die ganze die
ganze geschichte weil sich eben leute
einfach nicht mehr ein quarantäne
begeben aus angst eben die hälfte ihres
lohnes wird 14 tage zum beispiel
plötzlich nicht mehr zu erhalten das ist
eine gefährdungslage aber da hat eben
die politik zu beraten und dieses doch
sehr eindeutige gesetz beschlossen das
eben aktuell gilt wir haben nicht so
viele fragen aber viele meinungen und
kommentare bei youtube oder auch per
mail und facebook natürlich auch und
vielleicht schauen wir dann noch mal
zusammen drauf weil es gibt hier eben
viele meinungen dazu beispielsweise
greens hit bei youtube schreibt
demnächst bei sportverletzungen auch
keine lohnfortzahlung weil selber schuld
du hast das angesprochen das ist
natürlich auch ein thema was jetzt was
diskutiert wird oder auch hier marie
rosa schrödinger schreibt bei facebook
dann müsste dies auch für raucher
trinker stark übergewichtige gelten die
kosten milliarden und nico schreibt bei
youtube ist es dann nicht auch unsozial
fettleibige menschen nennt er ist zu
sein also es ist nicht unsozial
fettleibig zu sein oder zu rauchen das
alleine verursacht bestimmt mehr kosten
für die allgemeinheit weil es dazu so
viele kommentare gibt vielleicht noch
mal dazu also hier wird eben viel
darüber diskutiert sollte das dann nicht
auch für andere gelten die in dem falle
ja risikobehaftet leben wie zum beispiel
durch rauchen trinken also in diesem
verwandt aber etwas anderes in dem einen
fall
habe ich an meine arbeit nicht erbracht
bin in quarantäne überbringen meine
arbeit nicht und will etwas vom staat
und im anderen fall bin ich bin ich
erkrankt und da geht es um die
gesundheitsversorgung und nicht einfach
nur um eine um eine geldleistung das ist
eine bedeutende ich den menschen die not
sind zu helfen die krank sind und da ist
natürlich der solidar auftrag der
gesellschaft viel höher anzusetzen als
bei der frage soll der jetzt obwohl er
nicht gearbeitet hat trotzdem das geld
bekommen da ist natürlich die
verantwortungs frage doch noch mal eine
andere
aber es gibt schon auch gerechtigkeit
problematiken die rechtlich relevant
sein können erläutert es auch im
angesprochen es gibt ja durchaus selten
aber eben auch die fälle in denen die
geimpften auch das virus weiter
übertragen die geimpften müssen aber
nicht in quarantäne
also ist eigentlich frage auch ein stück
weit früher anzusetzen ist eigentlich
die quarantäne verfassungsrechtlich
gerechtfertigt und das wird man
wahrscheinlich über jahr müssen wenn
eine angespannte cupid 19 situation
besteht weil eben die ungeimpften doch
offensichtlich dass wir uns doch sehr
viel stärker verbreiten aber ganz so
dass die geimpften völlig ungefährlich
sind ist es eben auch nicht so dass ich
auch hier in gewisse schwierigkeiten
gerechtigkeit fragen stellen und
natürlich steckt man jetzt auch mit
rauchen oder trinken oder übergewicht
haben auch niemand anderen an das kommt
wahrscheinlich da auch noch luft zu und
jetzt sprechen ja kritikerinnen und
kritiker auch immer wieder von so etwas
wie einer impfpflicht durch die
hintertür die das auch dass die das
jetzt auch wieder sein soll wie ist das
denn rechtlich zu bewerten ja das ist
jetzt erst mal die frage karl lauterbach
wo sie abstreiten dass überhaupt eine
impfpflicht durch die hintertür ist er
sagt ja das hat gar keine wirkung denn
die leute wenn sie nicht impfen lassen
sollen die leute werden einfach nicht
das ganze einfach nicht melden und die
rk ii tagesberichte sagen ja auch die
gesundheitsämter kommen nicht hinterher
so dass die meisten leute die kantine
gehen eben oder 50m dass das freiwillig
tun insgesamt impfpflicht durch die
hintertür ist aber wie stark ist der
druck wie stark ist der druck und sagen
wir so in vielen ländern gibt es ja
sogar die impfpflicht oder bei uns gibt
es ja auch sogar die impfpflicht ja und
ich sag mal so wenn man dann gibt viele
gute argumente auch für eine impfpflicht
rechtlich auch viele tage meines dagegen
aber wenn man jetzt mal andere länder
vergleichbar sogar eine impfpflicht gibt
und während wir so eine mittelbare zwang
zur impfpflicht nach dem motto mir geht
es besser ich habe mehr vorteil wenn ich
geimpft bin ja erst recht zulässig ist
ja klar ich
würde sagen es ist natürlich immer ein
eingriff in die freie selbstentfaltung
das persönlichkeitsrecht der immer gut
begründet sein muss und man muss schon
sehen bei den ungeimpften meines
erachtens ist es so
diesen stückweit gefährden die sich ja
vor allem selbst und andere ungeimpfte
ja weil die meisten geimpften die dich
erkranken ist es ja zum glück so dass
die symptome wenn sie überhaupt
auftreten eher schwach sind gibt
natürlich auch wieder ausnahmen aber in
der regel ist es so und ich würde das
schon mit in die risikoabwägung hinein
geben dass solange die
gesundheitssysteme nicht überlastet sind
ein stück weit diese eigengefährdung der
ungeimpften rolle spielen mussten
allerdings haben wir ja auch noch die
kinder die sich eben nicht impfen können
da wird also schon noch eine weitere
gruppe gefährdet so dass ganz so einfach
dieses argument eigenverantwortung auch
nicht ist aber ich würde schon sagen das
ist eine gewisser weise rolle spielen
muss wer sich nur selbst gefährdet
selbst ein risiko eingeht der soll
dieses risiko eben auch eingehen können
wenn er keine anderen gefährt und das
muss man im einzelfall gucken das ist ja
alles sehr komplexe gibt es eben leider
gar keine einfachen antworten eine frage
vielleicht noch zum schluss das ganze
soll am ersten november gelten kann es
dann aber vorher oder vielleicht doch
danach tatsächlich so ein beschluss kann
der gerichtlich noch gekippt werden ist
daran noch was zu ändern ja also das wie
gesagt das geht ja jetzt eigentlich
schon ich glaube das ist er so die des
agreements die vereinbarung zwischen den
ländern das sind auch wirklich in die
tat umzusetzen
und je nachdem wie die konstellation ist
kann natürlich dann die arbeitnehmer in
die gerichte anrufen arbeitsgerichte
anrufen oder eventuell auch gegen den
staat klagen denn eines ist auch klar
wer sich nicht impfen lassen kann gibt
ja sehr wenige fälle wo man aus
gesundheitlichen gründen sich nicht
impfen kann die werden natürlich von
dieser regelung ausgenommen
es steht auch explizit im gesetz und die
müssen nicht befürchten dass ihnen der
lohn gestrichen würden sie nichts
zurückbekommen
vielen dank felix zimmermann für die
einordnung und euch natürlich auch
vielen dank für das interesse und fürs
zuschauen und wir bleiben weiter an
diesem thema dran und gehen natürlich
jederzeit wenn es irgend etwas neues
gibt auch wieder live bis dahin tschüss